there's
a bunch of i noticed there's a bunch of
videos online of you
having debates with um
these guys that built they were they
were in in the middle of constructing
this
uh zero mosque yeah it was an islamic
community center well that's what they
tried to change it to
so uh or is that there now it is not
okay uh i i was asked by some of the
families in 2009 to get involved in this
issue yeah uh where
uh some people a
an egyptian guy named sharif al gemal
who's a developer in new york um
decided he wanted to build a mosque at
ground zero
uh okay you know let's let's look into
us
myself and one of the family members
deborah berlingame whose brother
chick was the pilot of the plane that
went into the pentagon so her brother
was murdered on september 11th
deborah and i teamed up and we went we
actually went to sharif el-gamal
and we sat down with him in in his fake
office
and fake office yeah yeah fake office
yeah there was no papers there was a
couple computers set up there was no
you could tell it was just there it was
he he was trying to be like he's a big
shot developer
okay whatever he's uh he
in the end he was just a new york
shyster that's right you know
trying you know he wanted to um he
wanted to be a millionaire and he wanted
to hang out with
and do drugs with supermodels that's
what he wanted you know we don't think
he most people want that
i guess his ideology
you know i don't think was as bad as
some of the others we dealt with
throughout this
process right
and when we sat down with him we gave
him the opportunity to tell the truth
and we had done our studying and we knew
what the truth was
and he lied to us
even worse than that he would not even
directly address deborah because she was
a woman
so she and she would ask him a question
and he would turn to me and he would
answer to me he would not answer to her
and so when we walked out of there we
said this guy's
full of [ __ ] and he's a bad guy because
that's their culture right
well he you know that's some culture
that's not
an american muslims culture per se right
he i'm i'm trying to
walk a line don't you know don't worry
about it you don't there's but it's what
i believe
okay so um
for for example one of my very best
friends now is a guy named jason redman
who's a u.s navy seal retired who was
his team was he was lieutenant his team
was ambushed in
karma iraq he was shot eight times
including in the face
jason survived it um
and has become one of my very best
friends uh in the last five years
and if you ever
said something about
muslims as a broad brush generalization
he would go down your throat really
because
he was over there and he knew
the difference between bad guys
and good guys between right people who
wanted to do bad things in people who
were innocent
it's the same as being a fireman in
harlem in the bronx there's two percent
bad people and there's
98 just people who are poor
you know yeah i think that's i mean
that's definitely something that's very
present
in the air right now in the country is
there's a very
everyone thinks of things in
generalizations
there's there's no nuance to anything
it's either all muslims are bad
that's bad that's wrong all americans
are good you know what i mean
neither one of those are true right yeah
so what did you i mean
did you have a lot of contact do you
have a lot of like conversations with
with muslim people when you were
in that time period uh i i would say uh
i had some conversations um
and and people depending on which side
you were on people would try and brought
paint me with this brush or paint me
with that brush and neither one of them
was
accurate i i did
a lot of media in 2010. it became the
biggest news story of the year 2010.
it was a huge fight uh
between ideologies um
right and and in the end uh
they they tried to i was called
a nazi i was called uh
islamophobe i was called a racist i was
called everything and none of those are
true
no none of them i've never been that guy
in my whole life right
but i will defend the memory
of my friends at ground zero
and if you want to build
a mosque on top of
the grave of my friends
i will come at you and i will fight you
because not that you don't have the
right to do it
but it's very disrespectful
and it's very uncaring to our community
in the end we ran them out of there
and the the building
whatever it is is
still being built because they have no
money to this day it's still being built
yeah
if if you look at pictures around there
it's a high-rise luxury
uh condo building that's
halfway built and it's been like that
for years and years now
the crane is still there they don't
they're not doing any work on it because
they have no money
because the whole thing was a sham the
whole thing was a sham
and um we successfully stopped
that from being that ground zero mosque
from be
being built there which i i would say is
a victory
um but we
brought awareness of radical islam
to america and we explain to america
what that is and and what it's not you
know
a good friend of mine
she got very angry at me in these years
she's a pakistani muslim brilliant
american
doctor she's a brilliant doctor
and i i really had to explain it to her
that i that i'm not like islamophobe guy
which is a made-up word by the way
uh but but i will fight for
her because nida and her
friends her family and the innocent
muslims who come from
muslim countries to escape tyranny
they come to america america for for
freedom and equality
right right and that's what she wanted
she just
wanted freedom and equality that's what
like i said 98
or 95 i don't know the number but they
would they just want to live
in peace among christians and jews and
everyone right you know that's what she
wants and that's what i want
and i however that will not shut me up
when i find a bad guy and
and they don't they don't come after me
anymore i wish they would because i'll
crush them again